for US president Donald Trump right now
it's all about the investigations the
impeachment investigation into his
dealings with Ukraine and now another
one published reports say that the
president reached out to Australian
prime minister Scott Morrison for help
looking into how the investigation into
Russian election interference got
started and he's not alone his attorney
General William Barre reportedly did the
same with the United Kingdom and Italy
if true this would be unprecedented u.s.
officials asking allies to help them
investigate u.s. intelligence agencies
and the congressional investigation into
the Ukrainian controversy is speeding
ahead on Monday new subpoenas for
Trump's confidant Rudy Giuliani's
documents on his dealings with Ukraine
Giuliani responded saying he might
testify but is still claiming he is
Trump's lawyer which could imply
attorney-client privilege but analysts
Jeff Hauser says Giuliani has publicly
said something very different Rudy
Giuliani has said that he is not
actually Trump's personal attorney he is
doing essentially emissary work on
behalf of Trump as an individual on the
Trump campaign and that does not provide
any sort of privilege which would
protect his documents from going to
Congress the president has been taking
to Twitter into the cameras to pronounce
he's done nothing wrong the response
from Democrats in Congress will find out
and fast patty :
al Jazeera Washington and we can now go
live to Andrew Thomas who is in Sydney
for us so Andrew what's been the
reaction there in Australia
we haven't heard anything yet Divya from
Australia's Prime Minister himself but a
spokesperson for the Australian
government essentially said that this
was all routine that Australia's
government has always been ready to
assist and cooperate with efforts that
help shed further light on the matters
under investigation and the prime
minister Scott Morrison confirmed this
readiness once again in a conversation
with the president
what Australia's government also did is
published a letter that Australia's
ambassador to the u.s. wrote to the
Trump administration back in May saying
at that time when Trump had said
publicly that he wanted an investigation
into the Malloy investigation that Joe
Hockey Australia's ambassador had sent a
letter then saying that Australia stood
ready to help with that investigation
and all stop Morrison did in that phone
call with Donald Trump at the beginning
of September was confirmed that well
unsurprisingly perhaps Australia's
opposition party here doesn't see it the
same way Anthony Albanese II the Labour
politician who wants to take stop
Morrison's job in the next election he
says that this is all very murky and
shows a much too close relationship
between the US president and Australia's
prime minister a political relationship
one that goes way beyond to friendly
countries he said about an hour ago now
his assistance is in discrediting the
mullah investigation so he sees this as
a political investigation by Donald
Trump not merely a legal investigation
and that Scott Morrison should be
distancing himself from what is
essentially a domestic political issue
already the Labour Party here was saying
the Scott Morrison was much too close to
the US president Scott Morrison was in
the US on a state visit last week at one
stage he was onstage with the US
president of what looked like a campaign
rally in Ohio's already a lot of
disquiet here in Australia that Scott
Morrison is much too close to the old
Trump and this only feeds into that and
the Miller Inquiry inquiry has to do
with Russian interference into the 2016
election so why is Australia being asked
about it good question well in a sense
it all began with an Australian diplomat
Alex stood down Alice Alexander Downer
who was a former foreign minister of
Australia but by 2016 was Australia's
essentially an fast
he was actually a High Commissioner to
the United Kingdom he was in London and
got invited to a meeting at a wine bar
with George papadopolis who at the time
was working on the Trump campaign Trump
hadn't won the nomination of a
Republican Party but he was close to it
and over drinks in this London wine bar
Papadopoulos said - I stood Alexander
Downer that he expected Trump to win the
election in part because he knew the
Russians had some dirt on Hillary
Clinton and that they were likely to
leak that during the campaign well Alice
four eggs and a downer thought this very
interesting information he fed it back
to you can bura and Canberra in turn
felt that it was worthy of telling the
FBI about this information and all of
that led to the murder investigation
under Trump presidency so in a sense the
investigation
wouldn't have happened without that
initial conversation in that wine bar in
London and that conversation eventually
making its way back to the FBI
well George papadopolis has been on
Twitter early on Tuesday really
rubbishing Aleksandr downer and saying
this is his chickens coming home to
roost he thinks aleksander down there
was a spy essentially for the Clinton
campaign and he thinks this is all going
to lead to that thank you very much
Andrew Thomas in Sydney for us